okay so again
we're going to this drill he's going to
take turns hitting at that
hand okay and i am yielding and
disturbing
so it's not enough that i just
let him not hit me it's
he goes and i have his balance
then it's not enough that i don't want
to hit me
you don't have his balance by externally
pushing so whom you see
so i try to be relaxed
and i try to uh let his energy
do it okay so this isn't gonna be good
enough
i'm trying to relax
if your nugget is always on the
outside try to get on the outside if
they're always on the inside
try to get to the inside okay so that
you're always working
so
then be relaxed like emotionally
and i would recommend you don't throw
them every time
you're just wasting time on your breath
cycle
so i tend to just do little
little displacements
okay so
it's not really a skill where
understanding does anything to you
although if you don't understand what
you're
seeing then your mind dismisses it
as faith because you can't you don't
know what you're seeing
so let me give you some context here so
he there is an agreement in that he has
a target selection but it's an
upper thoracic cavity okay that's where
i want
to experience this okay
so uh when he goes and i
reach contact you do understand the
parry everyone does like that's what
stops it from hitting
but you don't understand how that
connects to his center
okay so the first way it connects to his
center
is that it does not contest even in its
parry so he goes and i'm not going like
that i did stop that from hitting me
but i i was not able to use his
energy in a kind of extension
and a movement of his center so
i do come up and i do make it miss me
but it has an inertia that's going
straight and i'm going to use that
inertia
[Music]
at such a rate and it's such a vector
that i do not stop him from coming in
and that i do not lose connection with
his with his hand
so i just gently extending it extending
and extending it
so this is different
different so extend
now the third element
is an internal aspect that i match
his um
energy value so there has there's so
much
uh there's a given amount of inertia on
here
a given amount of trying to hit the
target
a given amount of mass a given amount of
gravity
and i match that so that i create
the namesake of your art which is on
ikea
if i move at a rate
faster than his hand is going i'm going
to have a different
uh inertia in this direction a different
inertia value that he has
and that's how you come off of it but if
i keep the same one i can
extend it i also have
let's say he's doing that again and i'm
on the inside
so again i might move the target this
time
and i'll do it on the inside
and these little uh manipulations of his
center
are really that that was enough you
don't
you in training you can go like this but
this is enough that's enough versus
nothing
so just enough
and this internal aspect is conjoined
with
another internal aspect which is uh the
young version of that same one which is
the koku one
so for example going like this
he can feel this thing going you see
and he's going to want to pull it back
and that helps
generate more friction but i stay with
it
right he wants to do that so he feels
his center going back
if he does not or going forward if he
does not feel his center going back
he doesn't really pull back he doesn't
have to regain his balance
so when i get that inch and he pulls it
back
i just stay with it do you see and that
can bring me into
my second aspect as i aim that energy
into his center again so i have an inch
there
he pulls and then i push and i get the
balance disturbance
okay so let's say i go this way
he feels the push you see so he wants to
come around
so he comes around and i do the same
thing on the other side
in other words if i stay here he pulls
back
that's what you see and then the strike
comes again right
so but because i stay with it i can do
it
and then you're like why does why did he
leave his hand there
his hand gets kind of pinned you see
and in the same way that when he feels
his balance breaking
he pushes on me this time and that's
what allows the projection
but maybe he's smart and he yields but i
now stick with it again if i go to
push and he goes bump then that's when
you see that connection
so it's not that he's leaving his hand
on my hand
it's that i'm following his hand i'm
following his hand
so he went here got a little one
little extension of his center he goes
back
i go with it i attack he yields i come
around and i come back the other way
so wherever wherever he moves his hand i
just stay with it
wherever he moves his hand wherever he
goes
i stay with it it's not that he's
staying with me
which is what contemporary aikido does
okay
i move my hand and who gets job is to
stick with me that's not the skill
okay now it's a two-hand drill
so that makes it actually easier for me
so
i went over here let's say he pulled it
back
or he would have lost his balance he
absorbed this one
and maybe he comes for the second one i
do the same thing
i can do the same mixture so this time
as i go
in ikea adhesion here and he's trying to
push here
i deflect it into the kazushi pattern
and that's why he falls again okay so
if i uh i'm going with one hand
and then comes the other hand it should
be in such a way
that it is capitalizing upon
the other hand's kazushi pattern okay
so i don't want to go here here this one
these are not integrated
so the drill starts he moves i see
connection
and center right away so i press with
the coq aspect he's gonna do something
oh air he came in and with these two
hands i'm
doing the internal manipulation
i let the drill reset but i don't lose
contact with him
okay again he might want to lose contact
it doesn't matter i stay with him
so we'll do that one again so he came
forward tried to free the hand by going
back
and then oh there it is right there
we'll look at it again we did the same
thing he's coming around
and here it is right there so what is
what is there i stuck with him as he's
coming around
i push this out get the front part of
the front in
kazushi and then this one is the cocky
projection
in this center
so
here we go let's look at it again so a
lot of you
when you get to this point you forget
this hand
you you lose the the energetic
harmonization it's dead even if it's
touching
but instead you're using it you see
there's the
adhesion on the left hand and then the
coq projection on the right
um into the center
never never in his arms always into his
center
make him free his body
there it is so we'll take that last one
he's coming around and he's coming
around you see here we go
so he's coming around coming around and
boom he's going to hit the pokey
projection on his own
without me having to push him
just yielding him onto whoa
right there keep connection
follow his hands
see it's got a lot of stuff on this hand
going and
you guys tend to lose this hand don't
lose this hand
you use this hat
this is why poke hole is two hands
this is just called yoga
so you're you're like pull it pull your
arm on don't pull your arm off of my
connection
there you go you see you're like why
can't he pull his arm up pull your arm
off
you just follow it
so a lot of times you wanna you your uh
uk is trying to go back
right so they're trying to get off of
the stick well
that's the time to enter with your koku
koku's yawn
a lot of you go he goes to intern you're
like whoa and now oh you lost connection
and said follow it in boom
okay try it again
so uh he's got he's got
uh yoko man he's got ski we'll do
jodonsky
okay and he's got yoko man
okay so you can throw yoko man in the
temple
the eye socket or the crowd that doesn't
matter
okay so same thing he's going
and i'm going to do the same thing and
he
he's gonna keep trying these strikes
and again oh that would be a that's
gonna be hard right
so as he goes i'm finding the
connection i'm not waiting here oh geez
so
his hand goes and i already have it i
already have it
not waiting here boom not reacting so
seeking connection
and then yielding and into the same
projection so
he has to find it
and you're like you're like he does the
ski and you
he pulls his hand back and you're like
why doesn't he why everyone pulls their
hand back
everyone pulls their hand back because
you leave your hand here
you see if you go with him then
you don't lose connection connection
again
up and you're always going to see
he goes your yield is here you see
that right there do you feel the tension
i'm gonna take it away do you see
and then here is the adhesion right
there
you feel that just enough so go back up
rewind the film whoa whoa i was here so
i feel the pressure here
i yield bowl and then here is the pokey
so come back as his weight is coming
forward
into the ik adhesion he's gonna hit this
ground pop
won't pop
[Music]
so somewhere you have like these double
young arms
okay and you're confusing that when he
goes
um and that's a cookie projection into
his center
so i'm not out here hyperextended and he
goes and you're just fighting him okay
it's here wow there is
you're trying to do those three strikes
there you go
so we'll do that one again and he's
going one
here is the first yield there's this
hand is not really doing anything so
this one came back and did
the koku projection on its own
in this center in the center
so as close as i can get to standard
kokuho
a yin hand an eye adhesion hand
a koku projection hand a young hand
an outward spiral an inward spiral
and the front inward kazushi
the better it's going to be oh right
there
right here
right there
okay let's go